GONZALO RODRIGUEZ:
Since I was a child,
I always wanted to
create something
that creates an impact
on millions of people.
And with the use of technology,
we see that possible.
We can create great games that
reach and help kids be smarter
and grow stronger every day.
We are a small team that have
been working in the gaming
industry for the past 10 years.
Our vision was to be a global
company since we started.
The idea of the first app came
about when my niece asked me
for a new animal sounds
app, and everything
out there in the market was
full of ads. [? Shall ?]
we [INAUDIBLE] that let's
try to build our own animal
sounds app, one
with no advertising.
And when we launched
it, we started
to have thousands of
downloads every day.
For the first hour we launched,
it was only in three languages
by then.
We saw in Google Analytics that
people from all over the world
were using the app.
We said, OK, let's do it in
as many languages as we can.
We are a team of four
here in Argentina
that is creating the
initial part of the project.
We knew from the
beginning that we
had to build a very
big and strong team.
We started to hire people
from all over the world
to collaborate with us
in voiceover, language
translator, and editors.
In about two months, we released
the app in 15 languages,
and we increased our downloads
by 300% in only 12 months.
In order to go global,
you have to figure out
all the cultural aspects.
In our product called "Animal
Sounds," we have our pig.
And in some specific
countries, our users
were requesting us to remove
their animal from the game.
After removing the animal
from those specific countries,
our average rating changed
from 3.9 to 4.2 stars,
and the results for
us were just amazing.
SPEAKER 2: Ratings
and review section
is a powerful tool
in order to learn
from your community of users.
We are answering to them in
their user native language
with the help of the
Google Translator.
As a result, we have
seen a great improvement
in terms of user ratings.
In fact, all of
them are 4.4 stars
or even higher on average.
GONZALO RODRIGUEZ: Having our
apps in the Google PlayStore
is great for us.
We can reach millions
of people every month
in different countries and
in different languages.
Recently we have been
working on localizing.
Also, the pricing
is super-important.
Since we did it, we saw a
20% increase in our revenue.
SPEAKER 2: We
understand that Papumba
is like a bridge that can
connect kids, parents,
and teachers.
All of our products
are conceived
with the idea of empowering
our little users,
and it is so exciting to
create a mobile product
that you know will have an
impact in so many families
and houses from
all over the world,
In order to prepare future
adults in the best way
possible.